>>> HA YR WONDERED WHAT
A K HOLE SOUNDS LIKE?
WELL, SA HAS YOU COVERED JOININK
JUST HEARD IS-  MSTH
>> SUSF THEORETICAYS CITY OF NEY
PROFESSOR, WHAT  ACTUALLY EAR
>> WELL, SE PEOPLE SAY NOW
WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A A LE IS A
ESCAPE SOUNDE WHENELF CANNOTSC
HOLE, RIPPLINGHR T GAS CE
P  PLANET
EARTH, MASSAR,
AND AMPLIFIED BY 5OCTAVES, TITR.
ING TO BE ABLEOUTSIDE AND GO
AND HEAR A BLACK HOLE FROM O
ES IT MEAN TO
AR'T THE  TO THOSE OF US
OSIGNIFICANT OF IT?
>>ESRE
NO LONGEIOE
SPACE, MEASURE TM.
IF YOU WANT TO ALAE
TONIGHO  LOO
OF SAGITTARIUS, THAT'S
THE CE OERE,
MILLION TO 4 M
MASS OF OUN  ON EARTH
ARE MOVING AROUN
HOLE.
AND YOU CAN SE CONSTELLIOSAGITT.
ANYMORE.JUSTCI
WE CAN ALLE THESE
O SHOW ATUREND NEW ALLY, QTEF UI
ANTENOTHIS I JUPITERFROM NASA'W
TELESCOPE.
SCIEISG, QUOTE,
WHATUT WHAT
WE'RE OKAT IMAGEIT
THE HUBBLE. CAPABI
YOU CAN SEE RINGS, RIND
SEVERAL RINGIN ULLY.SEE NO
JUPITER, WHICH ARE
INVISIBLE FR TNEPLUS, LOOK AT T.
NORTH POLE ANDE OFDETAILS WHICHT
BECAUSE HULE A BLIND SPOT.
YOU FORGET T CAN
FRE  VIOLET, CAN OEQ ID
>> WELU EXPECT FROM EFORE. E I.
THE S
ANYTHING YOU'RE IN PARCU
FO
WND 5,000 G AROUND OTHER
STARS, BUT W
DETA OF THEME THE F THEM.
G ABTUALLY
PHOTOGRAPHAN IN THE
INCREDIBLE.
THINK OU
US GOING BACK TOCREATION ITSF.
THE WEBB I MACHINE.
F  GALAXIES ANSTARN YEARS AFTERI
SO WE'RE ABOUT